toujours à l'étranger l'irak a connu
aujourd'hui les attentats les plus
meurtriers depuis le début de l'année
une cinquantaine de personnes ont été
tuées et 250 blessées lors de
différentes attaques à bagdad et mossoul
la communauté chiite majoritaire dans le
pays a été visé ces attentats
interviennent après le retrait des
forces américaines des principales
villes depuis la fin du mois de juin
caroline since plus de neuf attentats à
bagdad dans des endroits très fréquentés
pour tuer le plus grand nombre de civils
les terroristes choisissent leurs
victimes des chiites
la communauté religieuse au pouvoir en
irak un bar un marché des ouvriers des
bus sont pris pour cible bombe placée
sur la chaussée voiture piégée sèment la
mort et la panique dans la population
les passagers sont descendus du bus en
mai quand le bus a redémarré il a
explosé
quatre personnes ont été tuées un
village dévasté près de mossoul dans le
nord de l'irak à l'aube deux camions
piégés qui explosent à une minute
d'intervalle les villageois dorment
le bilan est terrible 28 morts et 155
blessés et des dizaines de maisons
détruites
les victimes sont des chiites
appartenant à une secte
les shabaks al qaïda semble reprendre
des forces depuis le retrait des soldats
américains des villes fin juin
la sécurité est désormais assurée par
les soldats irakiens
bien moins performants les attentats
meurtriers s'enchaînent un échec que ne
veut pas reconnaître le premier ministre
chiite maman pendant le temps où les
milices d'al qaïda faisait régner la
terreur et contre les l'irak est
définitivement terminée al'approche des
élections législatives le pouvoir chiite
veut rassurer mais tous ne partagent pas
cet optimisme
non nous ne sommes pas convaincus quand
il affirme que tout va bien que la
situation est sous contrôle les irakiens
veulent plus ils veulent la sécurité
et la stabilité une population qui
craint le pire
la sécurité dans les mains du pouvoir
irakien proche de l'iran al qaïda
cherche à faire éclater une nouvelle
guerre confessionnelle à dix jours